uh what's your relationship I mean we
always hear that you and Cube don't have
much of a relationship but is there any
sort of like World in which you guys get
together maybe do another West Side
connection have a conversation like I
said earlier I [__] with who [__] with
me
um
you dig that's where I'm at with it if
you [__] with me I'll [__] with you but
if it's [__] me it's [__] you like I
don't I [__] with who [__] with me kill
you know what I'm saying and um I ain't
seen him or talked to him and damn near
20 years so there it is that's so crazy
what about Dub C
man it's just
man y'all got Classics together bruh I
totally understand Classics I totally
get it but you know that's I'm just the
kind of guy that you know I rock with
who rock with me I respect that man yeah
I I think most people should live by
that by that law yeah for sure yeah
there's the right size of bag though
someone comes in with the right bag you
know to to do Bow Down 2.0 I mean I'm a
businessman yeah
you get the bag you said you get to get
to the bag I'm a businessman yeah and
and it ain't never been me you know with
the hole up it ain't never been my
personality or or who I am with the hold
up of us
doing something it ain't never been me
as the whole up you feel me but
I [__] with who [__] with me yeah it is
what it is hey respect man yeah